[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial duels au sommaire
aujourd'hui deux principaux antagonistes
du moyen orient de l'époque l'egypte et
israël
guerre combat diplomatique qui a
rivalisé économique leur confrontation à
façonner l'histoire de la région toute
entière
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici une brève
présentation des dirigeants les plus
emblématiques de cette confrontation
entre israël et l'egypte c'est le blitz
levi eshkol est née le 25 octobre 1895 à
aura tough dans le gouvernement de kiev
alors partie de l'empiré russe au cours
de ses études à ville n'a qui deviendra
vilnius il se rapproche du mouvement
sioniste en 1914 comme plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de juifs de russie
et d'europe orientale et il décide
d'émigrer en palestine alors sous
domination ottomane en 1918 et je colle
intègre un régiment de l'armée anglaise
surnommée la légion juive constitué pour
lutter contre les turcs c'est cette même
année que né à alexandrie en egypte
gamal abdel nasser fils d'un petit
fonctionnaire il participe dès la
période de ses études secondaires à des
manifestations contre la présence et
l'influencé britannique dans le pays
nasser se destine à une carrière
militaire et entre en 1937 à l'académie
militaire grand pan les échelons il
effectue un séjour au soudan avant
d'être nommé en 1943 professeur à cette
même académie deux ans plus tard il crée
une organisation clandestine
nationaliste le mouvement des officiers
libres pendant la période du mandat
britannique sur la palestine et skol est
l'un des membres du comité central de la
haganah la milice d'auto défense juive
en palestine qui est constituera la base
de la future armée israélienne il est
également l'un des fondateurs du parti
travailliste israélien le mapaï après la
proclamation de l'état d'israël en 1948
et je colle est élu à la knesset en 1951
et occupe plusieurs fonctions
ministérielles notamment celles de
ministre des finances de 1952 à 1963
après la défaite des pays arabes face à
israël en 1949 l'egypte entre dans une
période de troubles et le mouvement des
officiers libres déclenchant un coup
d'état pour renverser le roi farouk en
1952 nasser devient le chef du
gouvernement en 1954 puis est élu près
donc en 1956 la même année il décide de
nationaliser le canal de suez ce qui
déclenche par réaction une opération
franco britannique associé à une attaque
israélienne contre l'egypte cependant
sous la pression de l'urss et des états
unis les alliés sont contraints de
retirer leurs troupes lorsque david ben
gourion démissionne de son poste de
premier ministre en 1963 eshkol est
choisie pour lui succéder
le nouveau premier ministre mène une
diplomatie active devenant le premier
chef de gouvernement israélien à se
rendre à washington en 1967 face aux
tensions croissantes avec les pays
arabes voisins il forme un gouvernement
d'unité nationale et nomme moshe dayan
ministre de la défense après la guerre
des six-jours sa santé décline et il
meurt d'une crise cardiaque en 1969
après la crise de suez la popularité de
nasser est à son maximum
cependant en 1967 egypte et ses ailiers
jordanien syrien et irakien et suit une
terrible défaite face à israël
nasser reste pouvoir mais meurt quelques
années plus tard en 1970
quatre guerres des centaines d'incidents
frontaliers et des milliers de victimes
des deux côtés les relations entre
israël et l'egypte n'ont jamais été
simples deux poids lourds régionaux
défendent deux visions opposées de la
région et se livrent à une bataille sans
pitié dans les domaines de l'économie de
la diplomatie et de la défense cette
rivalité abouti en 1967 à la guerre des
six jours qui privera l'egypte de la
bande de gaza et du sinaï le caire ne
reprendra ce dernier qu'après l'accord
de paix historique de 1979 premières
état arabe à reconnaître israël egypte
en paiera un lourd tribut au sein de la
communauté arabe d'ailleurs la paix avec
l'état hébreu n'est pas non plus très
solide un certain nombre de sujets vont
empoisonner les relations bilatérales
dans les années à venir quelle empreinte
la rivalité égypto israélienne at elle
laissé sur la région comment les deux
états ont-ils défendu leurs intérêts
nationaux et comment ces relations et
les lui et jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour
répondre à toutes ces questions nous
rejoignons antoine basbous politologue
directeur et fondateur de l'observatoire
des pays arabes monsieur basbous bonjour
bonjour quelles sont les origines de
l'opposition entre l'egypte et israël se
réduit-elle à l'opposition pays arabes
état hébreu d'abord avant l'arrivée de
l'état hébreu il y avait une
colonisation qui a été perçu comme une
agression contre les palestiniens et
comme l'egypte était en quelque sorte
les leaders des pays arabes le pays le
plus peuplé le plus puissant et comme il
y avait des négociations pour qu'il y
ait le siège de la ligue arabe au caire
donc les égyptiens se sont sentis
responsables de relever ce défi de
maintenir les palestiniens dans leur
pays et de contrer cette ce qui est
apparu à l'époque comme une agression
israélienne qui voulait chasser les
palestiniens pour prendre leur place et
créer leur propre pays pensez vous que
la personnalité des dirigeants des deux
côtés beaucoup influencé cette relation
d'affrontements forcément parce que
c'est une affaire de posture c'est à
dire que autant les dirigeants égyptiens
voulaient relever les défis et montrer
qu'ils sont les chefs digne de ce monde
arabe que de l'autre côté ce qui est
avait envisagé la création de l'état
israélien était extrêmement déterminé il
y avait la shoah qui était passé par là
il y avait énormément de souffrance chez
les juifs et il y avait une certaine un
certain soutien une solidarité
internationale
pour leur cause qui a été manifesté
notamment par la promesse de lord
balfour de crier au d'aidé à la création
d'un foyer national juif en palestine
donc d'un côté comme de l'autre il y
avait de la détermination évidemment que
l'initiative revenait
au dirigeant israélien de l'époque et
qui voulait absolument réussir la
création de foyers qui est devenu un
état que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
les personnalités et des dirigeants
commentait l'ont influencé ses relations
un peu tumultueuse au début par exemple
si on prend à levi eshkol et nasser un
exemple écouter
nasser ne pouvait pas imaginer un seul
instant plié devant des dirigeants
israéliens
nasser a fini sa carrière
sur des échecs face aux israéliens ben
gourion le fondateur de l'état d'israël
et ses successeurs peut imaginer que
jour une fois que le fait accompli sera
définitivement établi ouvrons à ce
moment là un accord avec leurs voisins
et ne seront plus totalement isolés de
leur environnement à la stratégie
d'israël a toujours été de saint céré et
de s'intégrer et de devenir un état
normal dans cet ensemble
projetant talent merci beaucoup monsieur
basbous nous allons poursuivre notre
analyse tout de suite mais nous vous
retrouverons à la fin de cette émission
pour plus de détails sur ce thème merci
encore à peine proclamé en 1948 le
nouvel état d'israël se voit déclarer la
guerre par cinq états arabes dont
l'egypte ce conflit dont les raisons
sont historiquement complexe prend ses
racines dans les événements politiques
et diplomatiques de la première moitié
du 20e siècle au fil des siècles les
arabes et les juifs vivent côte à côte
en palestine
à la fin du 19e siècle les juifs ne
constitue qu environ 8 pour cent de la
population
pourtant leur nombre augmente jusqu'à
28% en 1936 suite à l'idée d'y créer un
état juif qui se propage à cette époque
après la seconde guerre mondiale la
migration juive continue faisant grimper
la tension en 1947 nouveau tournant la
grande-bretagne renonce à son mandat sur
la palestine qu'elle détient depuis 1923
l'année même l'assemblée générale de
l'onu a adopté le plan de partage de la
palestine selon le document elle est
divisée en trois parties un état arabe
un état juif et la ville de jérusalem
censé rester sous contrôle international
les juifs accepte volontiers ce plan
tandis que les arabes palestiniens le
rejeter le qualifie d'injuste le
lendemain du vote un vent de violence
balaye la palestine manifestation
antisémite attentats et meurtres
les juifs eux aussi commencent les
préparatifs d'un éventuel conflit le 14
mai 1948 la grande-bretagne retire ces
dernières troupes de palestine le jour
même où les juifs proclame l'état
d'israël le 15 mai 1948 au lendemain de
la proclamation de l'état d'israël les
armes et d'égypte de transjordanie de
syrie du liban et d'irak entre sur le
territoire de l'ancienne palestine
mandataire pour empêcher le partage
territorial
l'egypte participent à l'envoi de corps
expéditionnaire aux côtés des syriens
irakiens et 30 jordaniens et même si les
armées arabes réussissent à capturer de
vastes territoires au début le rapport
de force change par la suite en faveur
des forces israéliennes mieux préparés
sur le plan de l'organisation militaire
résultats israël étend son contrôle sur
près de la moitié des territoires
destinés selon le plan onusien à l'état
arabe la rive ouest du jourdain est
occupée par la transjordanie alors que
la bande de gaza est contrôlée par
l'egypte
mécontente de cet état de chose l'egypte
est tout de même contrainte de signer
l'armistice avec qu'israël en 1949
cependant cette paix restera fragile les
deux états s'engagent par exemple dans
un combat diplomatique au sujet des
réfugiés palestiniens pour qu'ils
l'egypte
exigent le droit du retour sur le
terrain les tensions frontalières
devienne le quotidien de l'egypte et
d'israël au cours des années 50
les zones les plus touchées sont la
bande de gaza et le sinaï l'état hébreu
déplore l'activité des groupes
terroristes palestiniens qui peinait
tension son territoire en provenance
d'égypte et planifient des attentats
causant des dizaines de victimes parmi
les civils en représailles tel-aviv mène
des raids militaires sur le territoire
égyptien instable à cette époque la
situation sécuritaire se complexifie
davantage avec une pression économique
de la part de l'egypte dès la fin de la
guerre d'indépendance le caire bloquent
régulièrement le passage des navires
israéliens par le canal de suez
plusieurs plaintes sont portés par
israël devant le nu mais l'egypte réfute
les accusations israéliennes et prétend
exercer le droit à l'autodéfense la
ligne rouge est franchie en 1956 lorsque
le président égyptien gamal abdel nasser
annonce la nationalisation du canal de
suez c'est ainsi que les britanniques et
les français principaux actionnaires du
canal ainsi qu'israël décide
d'intervenir militairement contre
l'egypte le royaume uni et la france
bombarde l'aviation égyptienne au sol ce
qui permet à l'armée isralienne d'avancé
dans le sinaï tu es à gaza
la victoire militaire est
incontestablement du côté d'israël du
royaume uni et de la france pourtant
sous la pression soviétique américaine
l'armée isralienne évacuent le sina et
gaza qui repasse de nouveau sous
administration égyptienne ayant pas reçu
le soutien des pays occidentaux au début
des années 50 nasser se voient obligés
de se tourner vers moscou en 1955 le rss
et les gypsies un accord qui prévoit des
livraisons d'armements à hauteur de 250
millions de dollars en provenance de
l'urss et de la tchécoslovaquie au cours
des années 50 et 60 l'egypte restera
l'un des partenaires que de moscou dans
la région dans la même période israël
nous des liens étroits avec la france
qui lui livre désarmement le
rapprochement israélo américain lui
commencera sous l'administration kennedy
au début des années 60 ayant pour
objectif de créer un contrepoids à l
influence soviétique croissante dans la
région washington dépasse vite la france
en termes de livraisons d'armes à son
nouvel allié pourtant dans la région
israël se retrouve isolé son seul allié
de poids et l'iran avec qui l'état
hébreu maintiendra une étroite
coopération sur les plans militaire
technologique agricole et pétroliers
jusqu'à la révolution islamique en 1979
l'egypte au contraire monte contre
israël un véritable front sous son
impulsion la ligue arabe signe en 1950
le pacte de sécurité collective en vertu
de ce document les états arabes
s'engagent à se défendre mutuellement en
cas d'agression militaire dirigée contre
l'un de ses membres s'ensuit le pacte de
défense mutuelle avec l'arabie saoudite
à un rapprochement avec la syrie en 1958
les deux états forme la république arabe
unie c'est la réalisation des idées
panarabiste d'un acer la république
arabe unie existera jusqu'au coup d'état
de 1961 en syrie et son retrait de
l'union alors comment la confrontation
ultérieures entre l'egypte et israël
fera t-elle basculer le rapport de
forces dans la région qu'est ce qui a
poussé les deux adversaires a signé un
accord de paix en 1979
quels sujets de discorde empoisonne
toujours les relations israélo
égyptiennes
la réponse après la pause ans
[Musique]
deux principaux antagonistes du
moyen-orient' de l'époque l'egypte et
israël se sont trouvés officiellement en
état de guerre pendant plus de trente
ans le pic de leur confrontation est la
guerre des six jours à la veille de la
guerre israël et l'egypte sont des
rivaux quasi égaux dans de nombreux
domaines du point de vue militaire
l'armée israélienne est comparable à
celle de l'egypte en termes d'effectifs
de 164 1000 soldats égyptiens contre 240
milles pour israël sur le plan technique
l'armée égyptienne possède mille 200
chars et 500 avions de combat alors
qu'israël n'a sa disposition que 800
chars et 300 avions de combat pourtant
l'armée israélienne et mieux s'entraîner
dans le domaine économique l'économie
israélienne connaît une croissance
rapide l'industrie la production textile
les infrastructures de transport et
d'énergie
s'ils développent en egypte nasser
effectué la nationalisation de
l'économie est mise sur le développement
de l'industrie pourtant l'agriculture
continue de jouer un rôle clé dans
l'économie l'egypte mène une forte
activité diplomatique dont l'objectif
est encerclée israël il s'agit avant
tout du partenariat avec la syrie et la
jordanie à l'international le caire
coopère activement avec l'urss et la
tchécoslovaquie qui lui fournissent des
armes israël lui s'appuie principalement
sur l'aide des etats-unis de la france
et du royaume uni la guerre des
six-jours et précipitée par l' escalade
graduel à la frontière israélienne
depuis le milieu des années 60 or la
source de ces tensions n'est pas à
chercher du côté égyptien mais plutôt
chez son allié la série le conflit
autour des ressources en eau a provoqué
plusieurs incidents à la frontière
israélo syrienne depuis
1964 l'egypte elle regarde cette
escalade un oeil de plus en plus inquiet
l'étincelle qui met le feu aux poudres
arrive en 1967 l'urss annonce savoir qui
serait la masse ses troupes à la
frontière avec la syrie pour défendre
son allié l'egypte décidé d'une
mobilisation générale
l'information soviétique s'avèrent
erronés mais le pas est déjà franchie
la demande du président égyptien nasser
les troupes de l'onu quitte le sina et
ouvre l'armée égyptienne la voie vers la
frontière avec israël puis l'egypte bloc
le détroit de tiran coupant l'accès au
port israélien d'eilat nasser veut se
poser en héros du monde arabe et le
rassembler derrière lui au nom de la
cause palestinienne
en plus de la série il conclu une
alliance avec la jordanie et l'irak et
reçoit l'appui de l'algérie du soudan et
d'autres pays arabes face à cette
coalition arabe et israël tente de
rallier ses propres alliés mais
washington paris et londres refuse de
l'appui directement confions pourtant en
ses forces et je colle décide de se
lancer seul le 5 juin israël réagi aux
menaces de l'egypte et bombarde ses
bases aériennes ainsi que celles de la
jordanie et de la syrie israël s'assure
de la supériorité de total dans les airs
et lancent une attaque terrestre sur les
trois fronts en six jours l'état hébreu
annexe le sinaï égyptien la bande de
gaza la cisjordanie et jérusalem est
ainsi que le plateau du golan syrien des
gains gigantesque pour des pertes
minimes côté arabe vingt mille morts le
cessez le feu est instauré grâce aux
efforts de l'onu qui refuse de
reconnaître les équipes territoriaux
isralien l'état hébreu lui refuse de
céder ses conquêtes c'est ainsi que naît
la dispute sur ses frontières qui
persistent jusqu'à ce jour la
souveraineté israélienne sur le golan et
la cisjordanie et reste la pierre
d'achoppement de toutes les tentatives
de paix israélo palestiniennes
maintenant que les israéliens ont eu
pour la première fois la possibilité de
se rendre dans des zones d'importance
historique pour eux il serait difficile
pour nos citoyens de comprendre que le
gouvernement décide tout simplement de
les rendre la guerre des six-jours
catalyse la solidarité arabe face à
israël en septembre 1967 la ligue arabe
se réunit à khartoum tous différents
oubliez les pays de la région adoptent
une stratégie commune face à israël
c'est le principe des trois non non à la
paix avec israël non négociation avec
israël et non la reconnaissance de
l'état d'israël ce principe va guider
les relations israélo arabe pendant des
décennies le rss auront aussi ses
relations avec l'état hébreu s engage
encore plus auprès du caire désormais
plus confiant dans ses forces nasser n'a
qu'une seule ambition récupérer le sinaï
et pour cela il suit une nouvelle
tactique je ne peux pas envahir le sinaï
mais je peux casser le moral d'israël à
l'usure l'egypte s'engage donc dans une
guerre d'usure avec israël il s'agit d'
opérations sporadiques d'artillerie ou
d'aviation mené tout le long du canal de
suez elle débute en 1968 avec l'appui de
l'urss côté égyptien ce qui inquiète de
plus en plus les états unis en 1970
après un combat aérien israël aux
soviétiques washington et moscou pousse
les deux parties un cessez le feu il
prend effet en août 1970 un mois près
nasser moeurs anouar el sadate lui
succède en y serait le chef d'état
change aussi golda mais reprend les
rênes du pays en 1969 c'est le début
d'un long processus de normalisation qui
connaîtra des hauts et des bas le
nouveau chef d'état égyptien anouar el
sadate comment son mandat juste après
l'instauration du cessez le feu avec
israël il veut profiter de l'éclaircie
pour dissiper les nuages
contrairement à nasser el sadate estime
que des négociations avec israël sont
possibles il montre sa bonne volonté dès
1971 en proposant un traité de paix
partiel en échange du retrait partiel
des israéliens du sinaï israël refuse
pour le rassurer el sadate se détournent
de alliance avec le rss et cherche le
patronage américain en 1972 il expulse
quinze mille conseillers militaires
soviétiques puis envoie des diplomates à
washington pour négocier son offre de
paix ces tentatives ne se soldent
pourtant pas par un succès vers 1973 el
sadate se résout à la guerre pour
pousser tel-aviv à la négociation si
nous pouvions reprendre ne serait-ce que
4 pouces du territoire du sénat y est
nous y établir si fermement qu aucun
pouvoir au monde ne pourrait nous en
déloger alors toute la situation
changerait à l'est à l'ouest par tous
premièrement nous nous débarrassons riom
de l'humiliation que nous endurons
depuis la défaite de 1967
le 6 octobre 1973 le jour de la fête de
yom kippour l'egypte et la syrie attaque
israël dans le plateau du golan et le
sinaï l'armée égyptienne réussi à
traverser le canal de suez et la ligne
bar lev la série reprend le golan israël
est pris de court mais en quelques jours
seulement il réussit à repousser
l'ennemi el sadate ouvre aussi un autre
front économique cette fois les pays
arabes de l'opep réduisent leur
production de pétrole qui imposent un
embargo pétrolier contre washington
allié d'israël les prix bondissent et le
déficit s'installe c'est le premier choc
pétrolier vers la fin octobre l'urss et
les etats-unis se préparent à intervenir
militairement dans le conflit sous
pression et face au risque d'une guerre
nucléaire israël doit accepter la
médiation sous les auspices américain en
janvier 1974 israël et l'egypte signe
une paix partiel le caire promet la non
belligérance et rétablit les relations
avec washington l'embargo pétrolier est
donc levé en échange qu'israël se retire
à 20 miles à l'est du canal de suez
septembre 1975 c'est l'accord si nike 2
israël se retire davantage arles est le
caire ouvre le canal de suez au commerce
israélien ce n'est pas encore la paix
définitive mais les premiers pas sont
faits entre temps l'egypte rompt
définitivement avec le rss et se tourne
vers washington pour acheter des armes
en 1977 el sadate tente l'impensable il
se rend en israël et s'exprime devant la
knesset toutes vies perdues à la guerre
est une vie humaine que ce soit celle
d'un marabout celle d'un d'israël je
vous dis aujourd'hui jeudi au monde
entier que nous acceptons de vivre avec
vous dans une paix durable et juste le
monde arabe est en colère il condamne le
geste égyptien en mars
1978 israël intervient au liban
les pays de la région estime que cette
confiance de tel-aviv c'est l'egypte qui
la procurer el sadate lui reste
déterminé à reprendre le sinaï est riche
en pétrole du coup en 1978 il accepte
l'invitation américaine à kant des vides
pour négocier avec son homologue
israélien menahem begin en septembre
l'effort abouti aux fameuses accorde
campent des vides israël s'engage à
quitter définitivement le sinaï dans les
trois ans et washington promet son aide
économique à l'egypte en échange de la
paix la reconnaissance officielle et
l'établissement des liens diplomatiques
en mars 1979 le traité de paix est enfin
signé le rideau de fer tombe l'egypte
est le premier pays arabe à reconnaître
israël une position qui lui coûte cher
après les accords de camp david tous les
pays arabes rompent leurs relations
diplomatiques avec le caire sauf le
soudan et le sultanat de oman en
1979 à la suite du traité de paix la
ligue arabe exclu l'egypte de ses rangs
et transfère son siège du caire à tunis
jadis leader du monde arabe l'egypte
devient le paria du moyen-orient pour de
longues années pour israël le caire
s'affirme comme le plus proche
partenaire régional pourtant le problème
palestinien n'est toujours pas résolu
les gains de cet accord sur passe-t-il
les pertes régional pour l'egypte que
change cette paix pour le conflit
israélo palestinien
pour y voir plus clair nous revenons
vers antoine base ce politologue
directeur et fondateur de l'observatoire
des pays arabes monsieur basbous
pourquoi selon vous les forces
égyptiennes ont elles connu des échecs
chaque fois face aux forces israéliennes
y at il des causes récurrentes dans
chacune de ces guerres écoutez ce qui a
prévalu c'est la désorganisation
l'impréparation
aussi beaucoup de démagogie pensant que
l'egypte qui faisait plusieurs dizaines
de millions d'habitants face à un état
qui est naissant qui est en train de se
structurer bref il jamais fait des
raccourcis en se disant que le poids
démographique aller jouer en leur faveur
mais ce n'était pas le cas les sahéliens
était extrêmement déterminée ne laissant
aucune
place au hasard avait bien organisé lors
des postes leur leur guerre ou
leur initiative donc il y à cette
maturité israélienne avant l'heure qui a
fait que les à elle a réussi à défaire
plusieurs armées arabes à commencer par
l'armée égyptienne qui n'était pas ni
structuré ni préparés et qu'ils
n'avaient pas aussi les soutiens
internationaux et peut-être aussi que
l'armement utilisé par les égyptiens
n'étaient pas à la hauteur de l'art
moment que donc disposer quelles ont été
les conséquences du processus de paix et
des accords de camp david dans le monde
arabe et en particulier sur le rôle de
l'egypte comme puissance régionale
d'abord les accords de camp david sont
arrivés au lendemain du succès de
s'adapter face à la guerre de 73 c'est
pourquoi une fois l'humiliation
la vraie de l'armée égyptienne que
sadate a pu entreprendre cette démarche
qui était extrêmement osé
de d'aller à jérusalem et de changer de
camp c'est à dire à l'époque il y avait
les les l'armement soviétique les
conseillers soviétiques qui qui étaient
présents partout en egypte il a changé
de camp il a tourné sa veste il est allé
à jérusalem est il s'est approché de
washington en pensant que toutes les
cartes sont entre les mains des états
unis et donc
ça provoqué un choc une rupture au sein
du monde arabe au point que le siège de
la ligue arabe a été déplacée à tunis et
et que l'egypte première puissance le
premier pays arabe a été exclu de la
ligue arabe donc c'était quelque chose
d'exceptionnel par rapport à cette
initiative de sadate merci beaucoup
antoine basbous je rappelle vous êtes
politologue directeur et fondateur de
l'observatoire des pays arabes
merci pour cet éclairage aujourd'hui
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial à
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]